[تصفيق]
دخلت انا في الفريق تعتني من 80 وكنت احسن
مدافع ايمن تعملي هذه اللقب وكنت من احسن
المدافعين والمدافعين كما اقول لك
الامام وياخذوا الكوره من الدفاع الى
الهجوم وهي بفضل التحضير والتكوين لتكوننا
في الجزائر
لمدافع يقدر يصبح مهاجم
[موسيقى]
تعبان تعبان الرياضه
13 14 ذهاب ديت تدريب مع نصر حسين داي
وكنت اول انخراط في بطوله الشبانيه
1973 74 تكوين تاعي كان في نصف الحسيمه
حتى الاكابر مصلحه لاعب دولي
المباراه تاع الاحياء وكان مسرح
كره القدم
الالعاب الاولمبيه البحر الابيض المتوسط
[موسيقى]
المشوار هذا عده سنوات اكثر منها 12 ولا
14 سنه
ريال مدريد
المقابله والسما وها مقابلتها
[موسيقى]
كانوا يقولوا برشلونه
مصارعه 30 مقابله ما يشارك في كاس العالم
انا نقول خساره كبيره اللي كان كان عندها
فريق متكامل كانت عنده امك
[موسيقى]